بذريعه انعدام الامن ومنع التسلل وحده
مدرعه ايرانيه الى المناطق الكرديه
الحرس الثوري الايراني يرسل قوات خاصه الى
المحافظات الحدوديه الغربيه وشمال غربي
البلاد
الاجراء والذي تقوم به القوه البريه للحرس
الثوري يقوم على تعزيز الوحدات المتمركزه
على الحدود ومنع تسلل للجماعات الارهابيه
التابعه للجماعه الانفصاليه المتمرزه في
اقليم شمالي العراق
ان هذه الخطوه تهدف الى تعزيز الوحدات
المتميزه على الحدود من خطر ما وصفها
بجماعات الانفصاليه المتميزه في شمال
العراق
ودعا سكان المناطق الواقعه على مقربه من
المناطق المتاخمه لقواعد المجموعات
الانفصاليه باخلائها وتاتي حركه الحرس
الثوري الايراني بعد ان اصدر العراق
توجيهات لتعزيز الامن على طول حدوده لوضع
حد للقصف الايراني وفقا لبيان صادر عن
المتحدث العسكري العراقي
وكانت القوات البريه للحرس الثوري قد شنت
هجمات جديده ضد معارضين متمركزين في اقليم
كردستان العراق
عدا عن استهداف مقر حزب ازاد كردستان
بالصواريخ والمسيرات في اطراف محافظه
كركوك
وبرر الطيران هجماتها تلك في رساله الى
مجلس الامن الدولي ان لا خيار اخر لديها
لحمايه نفسها ممن وصفاتهم بالجماعات
الارهابيه و بينما تنفي جماعات الكرديه ما
تقول طهران وتصفه بالادعاء لا تزال
المناطق الكرديه في ايران تشهد غليان
وتظاهرات منذ اشهر اسرى وفاه ماسا امينه
ملوك الشيخ العربيه